oh hello everyone
so my name is ginger mama so head of a
hundred partner engineering in Japan so
today I wanted to introduce that a robot
and so that is a tightly integrated with
the Android so and also the Google Play
and Google mobile services and also
introduced another new SDK that is
enabling to the developer to making the
application so supporting to that are
these systems and also that Android so
welcome to the paper to join into data
under the family today so rolling from
the software chromatics so he will be
explained more detail about SDK today
and also write programming for that
paper for you guys and then paper of
course assisted at all and in the
discussion so Lauren please coming thank
you hello everyone I'm Luhan software
director at Southbank robotics and I'm
very thrilled to be here today at i/o
and we even brought some company as I'm
I know some some of you have noticed
earlier so this is pepper
he's a humanoid robot designed by some
Bank robotics and he's one of the first
mass-produced for about to serve as
emotional companion and the good news is
it's coming to the US this year so we
are happy to start supporting the
developer community but maybe we can let
him explain more about himself in pepper
it's an honor to be here as a speaker at
Google i/o we have a great show for you
I hope you're excited
are you guys ready
okay take a break
I'll take things from here so this was a
short dance to introduce you to the
capabilities of pepper and hopefully to
get you more excited about what we have
to share today so for the past couple
months we have been working on an
android sdk for pepper this is not the
first SDK we write because we've been
working on robots for more than 10 years
now but we thought and we wondered what
would be the best robotics SDK what
would make robots as accessible as any
other devices such as tablets and
smartphones and basically this is today
we want to share our conclusions about
this and we want to show you have simple
robotics development can be for anybody
so as you may have already guessed our
SDK for pepper is an Android studio
plugin it is already available you can
download it it's online and basically
you can keep the same tools and the same
habits you have because we basically
kept we want to get the original Android
studio flow because we know you are
familiar with it and this is something
that we really wanted to be really we
didn't want to change it so what we did
is merely adding tools to the existing
environment tools for robots basically
doing your application is exactly the
same way but we also provide api's so
that of course you can make the robot
move you can make it talk you can make
it interact you see what you would
expect from an SDK but more like
interesting tools such as animations so
you can use pre-existing animations that
we provide with the SDK and you can also
create your own we will get to that
later and we also provide a chat editor
so that you can script very simple
interactions with the robot which is
voice commanded
and ass but not least the SDK also
provide simulated robots so that even if
you don't have a robot which is probably
already the case you can already start
developing your own robotics
applications the for the rest is the
same so once your application is ready
you can create your pkg as usual and
maybe even publish them on the Play
Store so let's say we don't have so many
slides today because what I really want
to show you is the SDK itself
so on the left side you already know
this Android studio and in the upper
right corner we see Android emulator and
the last item is the robot view so the
robot view is basically a simulated
pepper and if you install the plug-in
for Android studio which would look
something like this
automatically you will have new features
added to Android studio to be used with
paper such as you will notice that there
are new buttons on the second line of
the toolbar here so the first one is
just to manage the SDK because you can
update them no more things and the
second one is to as I said oops so I can
restart it to start the emulator which
will automatically stop the tablet
emulator but also the simulated robot so
we have to wait a bit
and I said earlier that we support
animation and also chat files and these
are accessible as normal Android
resources using this little menu so all
the tools we are providing out there and
so you can create your boss application
you can have animation timeline which I
will show you a little bit later you can
create chart topics or chat files and
also import animations because we
already provide a library with very nice
and useful animations so maybe you can
start with a little coding because what
we wanted to do also is not to provide
the same usual way API is work you know
with service and modules our design is
based on actions so what is an action an
action is more like a task that you can
start and stop and it is it really
corresponds to something the robot is
doing so for instance a window draws
widgets and a robot will perform actions
so when you create a task you can like
set some parameters and then execute the
task and of course you can do it
synchronously or asynchronously which is
very important for Android and get
getting called back when the action is
finished things like that so if I take a
very simple example which would be like
to make the robot say something it would
look like training a say object
and then simply run it with the
parameter so for instance this wouldn't
be hello world but in Ohio now I don't
offend so much time compiling and
deploying so we have already
pre-installed the sample on the robot so
what you see on the screen would exactly
do this generally on very simple and the
robotics
so I said that we provide no tools
because running an application is not
only about writing code for robots you
have to care about a lot of other things
such as you know using the hardware
because we have so many motors that you
really want the robot to do something
this is why we also have animations and
our SDK allows you to use pre-existing
animations that our company is doing so
it provides four categories let's see
for instance action animals because it
will come back later in the presentation
let's say a gorilla animation so this
animation you can see the preview you
can exactly take it and import into your
project just as any normal Android
resource let me show you so we're happy
with this animation we selected and this
is automatically imported into the
resources you will see that the code
window has changed to look like you are
probably familiar with that this is more
like a keyframe setup because you can
edit those animations from the plugin so
if we look quickly here we have the
values of the joints so you know like
different motors and we have the
positions for the shoulders and
so we can change it and sometimes it's
not enough to just set the angle because
I could make like very you know jockey
animations so we also provide the more
advanced mode for the people who really
want to find you in their animations
which look like this so basically it's a
nice way to set all the tangents of the
animations and to control how the
movement would you know how you would
get from position a to position B so if
I preview the animation on the emulator
this is the robot you know entering
something and what I didn't mention
earlier is we can also connect directly
to a physical robot it's just the same
so if I preview the animation let's say
I want to change the position of like
the elbow role and you will see like the
difference instantly
well not-so-obvious we can see that the
right arm of the robot is moving like in
a different way so all this can be like
easily changed and customized and this
is basically how we write the density
that you've seen at the beginning which
is more professional way of doing
animations but again if you just want to
have an application with a robot doing
the gorilla you just use the prices in
animations let me show you a couple
other ones
so maybe animals are not so interested
interesting but when you write
applications and you want to have
interaction with a user you want to use
expressions like information
or exclamation and the words so hard you
can have like more complete complicated
stuff like emotions so if you look at
positive you know like blowing kisses
because it's a nice application
yeah so this is it for animations and
again this is like very important when
you write a robotic application because
you don't want only to display things on
a tablet you also want to have a robot
that moves and I can do like a lot more
things than just a normal device then it
works so nice if you can talk with your
robot so we've seen that yesterday
during the keynote vocal command is so
important and interesting so we also
provide a way to write your own sequence
script little interactions with the
robot that we call chat files so I have
a chat files already prepared here
so I will not go into the details of a
grandma but basically you can write
questions and depending on the answer to
that question reacts differently and I
will show you that on the emulator which
also prints out the application and
let's say you know you're working on the
plane or in the train or whatever and
you just want to test what you're doing
we provide the dialog view so here you
can type anything and directly discuss
with your robot this is exactly the same
thing that would happen if you talk to
it is just you are feeding the text as
for the emulator so for instance hi you
like comics
yes we side are you on
Steve Rogers or Tony Stark let's Steve
and the robot is turning me
so this quick example show you that it's
very easy to write your own sequences
and it can be very easy like this but
you can quickly get more complicated
examples and also have reactions tied to
that so you know like selling things at
all which is more interesting digestion
or talking
so all those tools again are directly
integrated into Android studio you don't
have to do anything else I just you know
installing the plug-in and using them so
I showed the things separately let's
look at a more complicated example but I
don't really wanna spoil what he will do
so let's first start with the
application which is already on the
robot and then I will show you how it's
written
Zemo aiyo this is my waving animation
watch we move and speak at the same time
hmm
let's say it again
this is my waving animation know
something in animation making robot talk
watch me move and speak at the same time
let's move and hopefully not fall
everything joke and you have the first
robotics elephant robotic joke ever
so all this which is already looks
pretty cool I'm sure you you really want
to try it and show it to people all
right you already have more complex
ideas I want to show you the code
because it's not so complicated
so I will not go into more details about
the oncreate you know we create the
activity and we carry it also a
different thread because for a few
statements you will see I want to block
and we don't want to stop the UI
strategy so create a new thread and you
can see that there is a stock method
which is just underneath which will
caught the wave method and a move method
let's look at the code of those so for
the wave the robot was saying this is my
waving animation and then waving so two
lines to make the robot talk you create
the sea action and then you just run it
with the appropriate parameters and then
the animation what we did first was
actually to import the animation the
elephant animation into the resource of
the project and once it's done we can
just start the animation using run so
yeah maybe more details you can see the
line with zero animation I import I
create an animation from the resource
hello a zero zero one and then I can
just run the animate with the Hello
animation so if you want to start a
different animation we just need to make
another animation from resources and
just play it
now together robot move it's a bit more
complicated but hopefully we provide
better wrapper soon still a bit gullible
what is important in that the robot is
in a 3d world the robot is moving and
you are so moving so you need to get a
good sense of where you are and where
you go or where things are this is why
we have what we call frames so you have
the robot frame which basically is where
the robot is and then you also have to
define where you want to go so that's
why you can see that the few lines of
math to get moving correct but again
hopefully we want to make it simpler
soon so we will just set everything we
want to do and set the target frame and
simply create a go to object here and
then run it and the robot will move one
meter so roughly
and then I don't know if you remember
but I touch the screen and you played
the elephant animation and play sound so
this is basically we have a callback you
know when I touch the the picture and so
you're probably already familiar with
the audio manager to just get the sound
and play it and him animation again is
the one same thing you just create the
animation from the resources and then
you just play it so that's it like you
know very few lines if you remove out
the border plate code you can start
doing things that are very interesting
and you don't even need to know a lot
about the robot itself you just use the
api's because this is what we want you
to do we want to abstract everything on
the robot side because it's a very
complex thing it's not only displayed
like there are many things to
synchronize and resources we do want to
have confliction these kind of things
and this is basically our job to give
you the right api so that you don't have
to care about these kind of things
so yeah I think it's about like 79th or
something and we have a pretty good
animation so this is now just an example
to show you about the SDK but I think
it's not like very interesting and it
doesn't give you like a good idea but
not very good ideas but we have better
things to show you that we've been
working on and we've prepared two very
interesting demos with Google using
Google technologies and we want to show
you those an aspect I would say is
better with the robot so we'll use the
physical robot instead of the emulator
thanks Lola so today we are going to
show that to you and other demos so
first of all is showing the magic ahem
we call the magic n so it's kind of a
gesture recognition
so most of devices in the mobile one
that is still using that to D
dimensional display so because the
difference between the mobile devices
atom so this kind of a robot that this
is this can be they express that any
reaction by using the three dimensional
things so that would be the wonderful is
impressive innovation for us so the
other one is we are going to show that
the tell presence today then so Roland
can you show us that there are first
round for that the magic hand yes so we
built a demo using tensor flow that
you're probably familiar with and we
wanted to use
sorry we wanted to use this really
starting encampment so we have to
translate here let's see the robot let's
see a good sense of is a very strange
obstacles like feet and mochi watching
panicked so this is not for your game
that's like a proof of concept using
tensor flow it sure looks the idea is to
detect some shape of my house
the magic signs to work you need to
first put me under your control using
the spell starter sign the magic book
says to hold up your right hand towards
me just like on my chest display hold it
for three seconds so the robots wants me
to do this for two seconds so that you
know it's enchanted
it's like it the culture of the robot
make sure you're using your right hand
and holding it in front of you so it's
supposed to see my hand and detect the
shape
so
let's see if you can cast some
higher-level settings in the robot makes
try tilting your hair to the right like
this so the robots now want me to do
something like this so
make sure you're using your right hand
and holding it in front of you you did
it now try the same sign but to the
opposite side like this
make sure you're using your right hand
and holding it in front of you amazing
maybe you should fix that Iranian cells
in this environment but very talented
wizard thank you
I haven't seen hands this magic since
the last night is that it might not
seems let's see if you can master some
other magic signs first put me under
your spell again whether the spell
starter sign so this is a very
interesting example because you know
with like very few things using
tensorflow and some learning you can
have a very interesting product with
applications in real life because if we
have this then we can easily have things
like pepper understanding sign languages
for instance and maybe someday because
right now it's probably difficult for
him but we could also have the robots
talking back so it would support a
different class of languages and
translations which would be I think
pretty cool so yeah this is using tons
of flow and we also have another like
very interesting example using other
technologies so I will show you
starting a pepper tree organs let's see
just a second
our obligation I found it is the dance
starting pepper telepresence
so is so there's something in the
trouble then so so next lemma is a
presence then you may have already
having that card about the stem we are
going to use the cold water demo with
the papers pepper has be a PPO and also
that another branch of a sensor in that
robot then we are using that video and
also the mic and they're also sending to
that at those data tree that mobile
devices you can see that's the
everything by through the accountable by
using that mobile devices and Carla mode
then if you are putting into data paper
to that your house then you can only
motor be seeing to that so stay there so
be your house and everything so through
their mobile networks so here we go so
we are using car bomb
oh and so it's not a really nice
environment but what is what would be
great is actually that when I'm speaking
the sound also comes out from the
microphones so I could be with Michael
Michael Ball
but this is like a very interesting to
represents this case because now I feel
like I'm the robots which is a bit weird
and this is also this is a very simple
application we are just using Google
technologies and simply putting things
together getting the cameras of the
robot and just using normal cardboard
development okay thank you so this is
quite new and then it's just a dumb just
before the i/o them
sorry for that some of the trouble then
so hopefully you guys do making the more
cool application and then go through the
Google parade and uploading to the
Google Play so that would be created
another ecosystem in the world so you
can so people will ashes to your life
and as so all your life of course
then that can be given the more of
treaty to that the people to be using
these devices in the kiosk devices and
also that any assistant for the attacks
is speedy kind of devices that would be
great in abrasion to that there are this
area so for thank you for joining to
that there this session and I hope you
to they are making the application
starting to the application sometime
soon then are ready to data Google Play
so thank you very much
you